so joe biden has coveted the day after
he announced i guess accidentally that
he has cancer uh whatever i guess this
is the world we live in where the
president of the united states goes on
gives him speech says he has cancer the
white house then comes out and says no
no he meant he had cancer before and
then the next day we find out the
president's being isolated but for coven
however he didn't say he had coveted
someone else did and then i jokingly
mentioned he did do a video about it
where he's like you may have heard that
i tested positive for coven and then i
was like he didn't say he had it he
didn't confirm it but this is this is
the weird reality of it that
either the president says he has cancer
and he does or he accidentally told the
world he did so anyway look now he's in
isolation it's a whole lot of weird
nonsense we'll talk about that we got to
dave chappelle to talk about he canceled
an event because uh this is crazy i
didn't know this but we're apparently
learning that people weren't going to
show up i think employees just dipped
out because i guess antifa was
threatening violence so we'll talk about
that plus we are going head to head
with the democrats j6 committee
full of garbage lies prime time show and
we are going to call them out and we're
going to call them out and we're going
to do it right but before we do
we're going to shout out our sponsor
tonight which is timcast.com that's
right tim cast irl is literally
sponsored by ourselves check out tales
from the inverted world season two
available now members only exclusive
show
this is um
audio visual podcast style images hour
long
stories exploring lost confederate gold
from shane cashman if you're into that
kind of thing we're actually getting a
tremendous response so i'm really
excited for this eternally grateful for
everybody who's super into this show uh
if you want to check it out go to
timcast.com become a member but don't
forget we're also going to have the
uncensored after hours tim cast irl
podcast up tonight at 11 pm as a member
you'll get to watch that as well i'm
also proud to announce that we have
removed paypal from the website
if you are a member still using paypal
you're fine but we're not a fan of
censorship in silicon valley so when you
go to timcast.com you're not just
supporting us when you sign up you're
supporting dan bongino who co-founded
parallel economy
a censorship resistant payment processor
service we are going to be building out
the infrastructure for not just our
company but other companies we're going
to use their services because we want to
put our money where our mouth is and
hopefully y'all will do the same and
stop giving your money to people who
hate you that being said i don't expect
everyone just to cancel their disney and
netflix because people like
entertainment right we're gonna make it
we started with this we got cast castle
we got tales from the inverted world we
got pop culture crisis maybe none of
those shows are your cup of tea give us
time we're going to put out comedy
specials we're going to put out more
shows documentaries we're going to give
you everything and then
the regular person in this country cause
not for politics we'll say i signed up
to timcast.com and canceled my netflix
because they're better and that's how we
win the culture war so don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and i will say
the reason we're going to be able to
call out january 6 and do it right is
because we are being joined by marjorie
taylor green hello everyone how do you
do you wanna
i know everybody knows who you are
but just in case would you like to
introduce yourself yes congresswoman for
georgia's 14th district very proudly
representing northwest georgia and i'm
excited i'm excited to be here with you
guys tonight thank you so much for
coming i think it's gonna be really
exciting and uh we also have jamie
kilstein hey everybody uh i'm a stand-up
comedian i know that marjorie is
controversial so i just wanna say off
the top whether you're on the left or
the right let's all come together and
see me do stand-up comedy houston texas
august 5th and 6th you can get tickets
at riot htx dot com i am also writing
for cass castle which is now up at
timcast.com we have new episodes that
are insane if you guys liked what we
were doing on the vlog you're absolutely
gonna love uh what we're doing now
because we have more time we're making
it like a real sitcom about the about
the culture war about all the characters
here and i'm gonna be doing some other
stuff to be announced soon also over at
cass castle uh you can also follow me on
twitter and instagram which you guys
have been and you're very funny and much
more entertaining than my old liberal
fans thank you
uh i'm ian crossland
looking
uh no ian crossland is
out of his seat tonight for uh personal
reasons anyways i'm mary morgan i
co-host pop culture crisis on youtube
i'm going to dutifully chill for it
tonight
we do a live show every monday through
friday talking about just lighthearted
content entertainment news celebrity
gossip that type of stuff you might not
hear about on irl so go subscribe
i am as always here in the corny pushing
buttons i'm so excited to have marjorie
back again tonight she's just a delight
to talk to and hang out with and i'm
stoked for what we talk about tonight
all right let's jump into this first
story from timcast.com
president biden tests positive for
kovitt reporting mild symptoms i don't i
don't know how much i should really care
about this story i don't know how much i
should believe this story but the big
story i guess is the rampant speculation
immediately president harris started
trending once again as it often does
whenever biden is sick with something
and then people started speculating as
to what's really going to happen and so
my favorite conspiracy theory i know
it's a conspiracy theory is that biden
or i'm sorry kamala harris will step
down
and take a prestigious job to fight
climate change or something biden will
then appoint to vp newsome
then biden will get 25th amendmented
where it's like his brain doesn't work
and he's incapable of doing the job
right news is already happening well
yeah i mean he accidentally claimed he
had cancer or he does one of the two
either way it's bad and then
he chooses stacey abrams to be vp that's
like the apocalyptic scenario i guess oh
well i don't okay well first off let's
say this cancer's horrible i mean
god forbid i really hope he doesn't have
cancer that would be awful and covid we
wish him well we hope he feels better
but he does have dementia and we really
need to know i mean he needs to you were
doing so good
i was like cancer's bad yes kovitz back
oh no but he probably hasn't i'm sorry
he's not doing well he's not doing good
and um but i will say kamala harris as
president would be fantastic because i
can tell you right now republicans would
definitely win in 2024 if kamala was
president yeah but i mean i feel like
they're going to win if biden's
president too because
can you imagine joe biden trying to go
up against trump he didn't do it the
first time he just he what do they call
a lid and then he just hid in his
basement yeah and they were they were
betting on people just hating trump now
you're going to put out a president
who's destroyed the economy who presided
over let's just say that the destruction
of the economy the expansion of a war in
eastern europe the first time since like
world war ii horrible food prices
through the roof inflation through the
roof gas shortages coming yep panic fear
chaos and then they got they got it so i
actually think kamala harris as bad as
she is it'd probably knock them up a
couple points
i don't know they don't like kamala like
remember when she was yeah when she was
in the primary she was one of the least
popular ones democrats don't like her no
i was a i was a i was a tulsi fella when
she ripped into her during the debates
about i mean she's done
horribly anti-progressive things uh with
with criminal justice in california i
mean it's it's been abysmal she like
bragged about slavery right she she she
bragged about well
previously she got she bragged about now
she's getting called out for it was her
office i believe that kept inmates in
longer to use as cheap labor to fight
wildfires and it's funny when i say that
and people go
inmates don't fight wildfires and i'm
like oh ho ho buddy read the 13th
amendment it allows for slavery with uh
after the conviction of a crime or
something that effect so yeah that's why
they can make no money but they're even
doing labor they give like a dollar a
dollar yeah risk your life in a wildfire
because you're an inmate yeah and it's
the best thing you can do and she's like
we'll deny their parole and just do it
this way also by the way remember that
the majority of prisoners in america are
also there for non-violent drug offenses
so it's not like they're like sending
just like a rag tag it's not like
suicide squad where they're sending a
bunch of assassins to fight wildfires
it's just like dudes who were caught
selling dime bags in the 80s or they're
in solitary confinement for going in the
capitol on january 6th pre-trial that's
right
yeah a 69 year old cancer patient i love
this they claimed you saw the story
right yeah so the prosecution said that
she was yelling for people to go in the
building and i was like oh wow she was
really
kind of like ray epps
like ray apps well where's that guy i
don't
know
you know that they they bring up this uh
people on the right mention the 69 year
old woman with cancer yes i've been
furious about it two months and
so then you hear the argument and
they're like she was encouraging people
to trespass and all that and i was like
wow she was encouraging trespassing it's
kind of like the media is it anything
like the uh bear staffers who lied about
having credentials
caused such a ruckus that a democrat
staffer called for emergency services
we're banging on people's doors after
hours and telling people they're gonna
be putting things in there under their
doors is that better or worse no you can
tell me it's the same i don't care it's
certainly at the very least worse than
what someone's accused of doing and the
prosecutor said well you know we
wouldn't get a conviction anyway so
that's a two-tier justice system yeah
that uh that same film crew was outside
my office they targeted my office
capitol police have it on video um but
yeah there's there's no prosecution
happen the office that actually allowed
them to come in is jake austin kloss's
office uh and his chief of staff is tim
heisem who is the guy caught on camera
and arrested by capitol police that was
targeting the sign outside my office
but no doj won't prosecute any of it but
yeah they put a 69 year old cancer
patient in jail for two months she
walked she okay she told people to go in
she walked into the capitol i think she
was in there five minutes that's what i
read and then she came back out she was
filming
she said that i like to film these
things yeah like what you post on social
media that everyone should come down and
this is what they do if you go on social
media and you're like everybody should
protest in dc and then everyone shows up
wearing the pink [ __ ] hats and that's
it everyone's fine but you get a couple
hundred of those people to then tear a
fence down and they're gonna claim that
your call for protest was actually a
call for violence that's right that's
what they did
but it's like the media uh uh talking
about all the antifa blm protest and
they were burning cities they burned
washington dc it was on fire it was
mostly peaceful a little bit fiery but
you know i mean everybody's let off
right it's that aerial shot of dc with
the fire everywhere the smoke coming out
all over the place did you guys see
aoc's recommendations for how to protest
she has a graphic
did you remember that a while ago do you
remember it's on her graphic that she
recommends heat resistant gloves whoa
yes oh my gosh it is
heat resistant gloves goggles and a mask
non-descript clothing and cover up any
identifiable tattoos it's like a how to
be a terrorist thing uh it was posted
during all the blm and antiphon riots
i gotta i gotta i wanna go back to the
biden covered thing because i want to
point out to everybody that one of the
most uh scariest symptoms of covid is
a loss of your sense of smell we have
this tweet here from thomas
massey what if he loses his sense of
smell
and it's biden's sniffing children and
women yes this could be the end of joe
biden
when he can't sniff women and children
he's like just let me again the other
day yeah he was well it's a thing he
loves to do it someone someone posted
they're like imagine wearing a mask
getting uh double vaxxed and triple
boosted and then you catch code because
joe biden sniffed you oh no
that's not good not good i had to pull
it up i know i don't want to derail from
the conversation but i was like this is
like
if biden were watching a horror movie
they would it's about a guy who loses a
sense that's what it is
it's just him riding an amtrak into the
sunset
leave me on this amtrak to delaware all
right tim i just texted you aoc's uh
post oh yeah of her protesting safely so
i just sent it to him and maybe he can
give it to you yeah and you guys can put
it up for that and uh from what i can
tell i haven't confirmed this
independently a news article saying that
biden has in fact lost his sense of
smell so all over oh boy oh wow you can
fact check it forward you know look look
i got to say
for all the faults of joe biden to take
to to revel in the loss of his one true
joy pleasure it's just it's just
should we have a moment of silence i was
gonna i was gonna try and do this for
him we should pray for him well i was
gonna try and get rid of his recovery
and a sense of smell no maybe we should
pray for it not exactly
i just i i really do appreciate margie
that you're a member of congress making
these jokes it's fantastic well i'm a
normal person right i'm a regular person
that's why a lot of people think i you
know they say terrible things about me
but uh yeah you know what i'll be uh
i'll be honest off the bat um when
i heard we were gonna be on the show
together i just envisioned every liberal
that i follow on twitter my family i'm
like god everyone's gonna hate me and
then part of me was like okay maybe i
need to get sound bites going after her
and then because of you marjorie i had
to watch a 10 minute very unfunny daily
show clip uh it was so long dude it was
so long uh all about you and i was like
this is terrible and then everyone here
was like dude you're gonna love her and
i'm like i don't know and they're like
you're gonna love her and then literally
before the show i was like i love her
so you were making me laugh you were
telling stories you were giving me
advice on my classes i know what your
glasses are saying right now jamie 10
years ago would be too scared to
actually confront jamie now
jamie 10 years ago would be like if i go
on a show with jamie in 10 years i'll
get canceled yeah yeah yeah i i would
just sadly tweet about it and then not
talk to this jamie face to face but you
know what jamie you know what i think
the deal is because i think most
americans we actually agree on more
things than than we realize don't you
charm me with that uh yeah no i agree
well and we were talking about this
before the show which is i love the fact
that
the
congresswoman that is talking about that
here is known as one of the most divided
because i say that on stage i do stand
up where there
in my show there are stuff where i make
fun of the left and make fun of the
right and everybody like real people not
twitter personalities everybody laughs
at the same stuff and then you go hey if
we can take that laughter outside and
just assume that you have good
intentions and that i have good
intentions and that if we talk we
probably have some similar values and
different ways to get to it would
probably be fine and then everyone's
like yeah but instead we're just glued
to twitter and facebook and cnn and fox
news and all these corporations that
essentially profit off of us fighting
they do and they and they put us into
sound bites
so you can make anyone seem horrible or
angry or bad in any way if you put them
into sound bites because you can twist
whatever these little bitty sentence or
whatever it is yeah people don't know
you actually went on for three hours
about jewish space lasers if you heard
the whole three-hour thing it was it's
so much more it made so much the context
was very stripped out
i know yeah there were poems in it which
was great me as a jew i appreciated it
yeah i and i and i funded them i voted
to fund them yes
i'm actually impressed with the
technology i think it's amazing she was
super proud of that here's the crazy
thing that i see though
i see people posting memes claiming that
you talked about jewish space lasers
which you literally did not do i never
said that phrase right i didn't even
know the phrase until they were writing
articles about me and i was trending on
twitter with the hashtag jewish jewish
space lasers i was like what are they
talking about
but i look at these memes and they're
people who genuinely believe you you
claimed that
and it was like dude i did i was just
like because i didn't research it you
see everyone talking about on twitter
and then you see real verified
journalists and you go all right well
that's the new crazy congress lady who i
got to talk about
us having space lasers or whatever then
you read it you were talking about pg e
yeah and investment firms
and it was like and i mentioned that a
rothschild was on the board
and i didn't even know they were jewish
i would describe it
i would describe it as that's so funny i
didn't know
i would describe the post as just asking
questions conspiracy theory internet
posting like you were very much like
it was it was all question marks yeah it
was like is it possible that this could
have happened i i'll tell you personally
i think it's silly but the fact that
they construed a silly post on facebook
into you claiming jewish people had
space lasers is just the it's it's it
had nothing to do with jewish people it
had everything to do with the technology
that was new that was harnessing the
sun's energy and sending it back to to
transmitters
uh to create create energy it was just
that's what i was talking about and
that's more like a mexican thing i'm
just kidding i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding just kidding crazy it cancelled
too i don't know or maybe that's what
happened to my forehead
actually burned it with a curling iron
they knew that if they tried to actually
say
here's what it is they find a post from
you
where i think
like
i don't know enough about the
transmission technology i have read
about how they do solar capture and then
they use uh i thought it was really
interesting solar capture energy
transmission to base stations in the u.s
has been stuff that i've read about in
sci-fi and then you uh were asking if it
could be used to start wildfires or
something no no i was asking i and i was
just asking
like
anytime there's something new right
whenever there's a new invention a new
creation is there a mistake like when
the wright brothers
started to fly how many how many times
did you see like brand new airplanes
people trying it out and they crashed
right i was just asking could there be
like a miscalculation and and and where
they're sending it back to could it miss
because our earth rotates and
things move in space it was like
literally just asking questions that was
it i wasn't i wasn't accusing anyone
especially jewish people i would never
do that
the post is nothing the post is nothing
the post is nothing and so there's no
story unless you reframe it as jewish
space lasers and i think it was in 2018
yeah it was insane let me let me tell
you i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna rag on
this because i know i bring it up a
little bit but it's a good segue
when uh i said this in january
how how are you gonna convict people on
january 6 of trespassing if the police
are on video opening doors for them now
obviously the people who broke glass and
are fighting with cops yeah they're
hitting cops of course you get charged
for that right the young turks did a
segment calling saying i had the
stupidest argument ever
and it's like they just literally
strawmanned and misconstrued on purpose
what i was saying
i was right a guy i think his name is
matthew martin was acquitted on all
charges because the judge saw the video
of the cops fanning people in
now some people were fanned in some
people the door's open aoc said so
she did but this is what this is what we
we see that is what we refer to as the
quote unquote left
is like
they will intentionally misconstrue your
post in a way to smear you because they
know their viewers aren't smart enough
to actually fact check
well they have a purpose in this story
right it's it's a political purpose they
don't want trump to run for president
again they have to smear him in as much
as possible they have to embarrass him
and everyone that worked for him anyone
that aligns with him because they have
to they want to stop him from running
for president again that's what this is
all about same as the russia hoax they
wanted to impeach him and get him out
and january 6 is another issue so it's
they target anyone
that that defies the their narrative
well and also what's so frustrating
about it is look me and you are going to
disagree probably on some trans stuff
we're going to disagree probably on
abortion stuff we're going to disagree
on
a lot of things right but
if
i'm just taking things that you didn't
say or saying things that are out of
context that means i don't have an
argument i would so much rather
talk to someone and find out what we do
have in common and then we can talk
about it so like abortion's a a great
example where
i used to just be no questions asked um
completely pro-choice and then i talked
to conservative friends and i learned
about some of the late term abortions
i'm like i don't love that but one thing
that i will always say and i will
vehemently uh
uh defend is i go hey
if we're restricting abortion rights
which a lot of the stuff i don't agree
on maybe we should also talk about more
sex education or more access to
contraceptives and i feel like with
every political issue there are
these middle grounds where it's like
okay if i give you this like how if the
goal is just
here's the issue the right is offering
nothing but compromise it is objectively
true
the overturning of roe v wade is a
conservative compromise
uh well let me ask you right
do you think abortion should be banned
totally
i am
unapologetically i believe in life at
conception i do i think that and i'll
tell you because i'm a mom i have three
kids
and there's nothing that i could ever do
in my life even if i became president
even if i created world peace i there's
nothing i could do in my life that would
be greater than being a mom because i
love my kids that much and it's i
consider it a true blessing
so and i don't think anyone is a mistake
i do not i believe that every single
person
that god uh has a plan for them even if
they're unwanted even if they came out
of a horrible rape or something i just i
truly believe that
there's a reason for them i wanna i
wanna separate this into two uh distinct
questions in the same area right there
is the political implementation of a ban
versus the personal feeling there should
be right do you personally feel abortion
is wrong and shouldn't be allowed yes
that's how i personally feel politically
do you think in the entire nation there
should be a nationwide ban on abortion
in every state at the federal level if i
had to vote on that yes i would vote on
that so
here's the issue but let me add to it i
do not think our government is serving
our the american people and we we should
do more for women we should do more for
orphans we should do more to help we
should help people and we don't do that
we send our monies overseas to foreign
countries we we build schools and walls
and and roads in foreign countries we
fund foreign wars but we do nothing we
do nothing to incentivize families flint
michigan needed water pipes for a long
time but here's my point what the
republicans ended up doing is allowing
the states to decide if they have
abortion or not
and the left is acting like i know the
supreme court did that i'm sorry yeah
the supreme court ruled
they gave the right back to the states
gave it back to the states and now you
have red states saying you know uh many
red states saying we're putting limits
on abortion and blue states that's a
compromise position the republicans
didn't come out and the supreme court i
should say could have ruled abortion was
completely illegal under the 14th
amendment the supreme court six to three
of conservative justices could have said
the 14th amendment guarantees equal
rights under the law and we hereby
recognize life at conception as a simple
moral principle they could have said
that they didn't
they went halfway and said we shouldn't
decide on this it's up to you guys to
figure out well
they they gave it back to the states to
decide because really our federal
government has grown way too big i mean
you could look at this in so many
different issues and avenues but giving
it back to the states actually gives
people more control it really does i
agree but you see the point the left is
telling you that you need to live the
way they want to live and they want
things in your state to be completely
the way they want them and you're saying
no no your state should be allowed to do
what it wants and our state should be
allowed to do our thing you're offering
up a compromise instead of telling blue
states to live the way you live you're
saying let's agree to disagree and
they're saying no to you that's the
problem well that is true but i'm also
sometimes in favor of a national divorce
because
i kind of get i get him started i get a
little bit sick and tired of him this is
why i'm like fighting mtg is like the
best oh i i'm glad you said of the
fighting because you paused and i was
like you're gonna say your husband
i i want to clarify real quick like
it is just
the jokes you make the points you make
you you're fearless i really respect
that thank you well i i look we've had
politicians on the show i've met with
many politicians i typically can't stand
them because
they won't just say what you said like
you just fearlessly will say something
as
potent i suppose as sometimes in favor
of a national divorce is a powerful
thing to say well i think it's a lot
better than a war i don't i don't want
to ever see a war a civil war would be
awful
god i hope not but it seems that the
divide and the just the arguing and the
vitriol and the hate it just keeps
building and building and building and
and it it's really upsetting like i've
i've been we were in session all week
this week and it's nothing but bitter
fighting it's it's just constant
fighting on extremism and extreme issues
and i i just feel like if we're to this
point maybe we should consider that you
have your you know you have your blue
states and we have our red states and
and we can all maybe figure out how to
get along and talk again after we
separated headline marjorie taylor green
wants civil war well they did that
watch that
somebody's going to clip that well so i
know they did that already remember they
did
there was that big story where you said
you said something about
uh you know this could lead to a civil
war and they wrote marjorie taylor green
wants one oh no i never won a war right
never you want to know why all these uh
gung-ho you know people older than me
they're if they think that they're going
to go fight in the civil war sorry old
out-of-shape people you aren't going to
be the one doing it let me let you know
who it's going to be it's going to be my
kids yeah and i don't want that and and
i think that's wrong we want a good
future for our children yeah let me let
me pull up this post that you referenced
earlier from aoc i uh you sent it to me
and then i pulled up may 30th 2020.
this is just after uh the george floyd
incident it's uh the summer of love some
some of the worst riding we have ever
seen in this country some of the worst
writing we have seen uh the most damage
and and lost since the 50s
dozens of lives lost
aoc protesting safely what to wear
non-descript solid layer clothes
solid layer clothing heat resistant
gloves sorry what
is that gloves
goggles mask emergency contacts written
down tie your hair up don't bring things
you don't want to be right so they got
they got they got a knife
turn your cell phone off i mean why
would you turn your cell phone off if
you're protesting safely
well i actually i if if it was just the
what was the date
may 30th yeah oh wow if it look
i'll i'll tell you what the one thing
that really alarms me and it's the heat
resistant gloves me too that is that is
her basically saying get ready for
terrorism yeah now look if you talk
absolutely why would you wear heat
resistant gloves molotov cocktails okay
i mean it could lighting a fire tear gas
canisters okay
tear gas can get hot when it's or or
cold i'm not sure which one is it is it
exothermic i don't know when when it's
um i think it i think it might get hot
i'm not sure
you're trying to find out if i'm
undercover antifa right now you're like
jamie which one is it well so when you
have your heat resistant gloves with
your baby compression is usually cold
right but i've heard people say hot so
someone in the chat can correct me but
arson wearing wearing insulating gloves
is literally about picking up tear gas
and throwing it or molotov cocktails or
starting fires but it says protesting
safely yeah okay well for you yeah to be
fair and this is not i've a list of
things you were talking about that i
would much rather defend than aoc right
now but could it also be which is
also bad
fire could be there this is how you
protect yourself not in sighting wear
these gloves so you can make fire
not at us not at a safe protest not at a
peaceful protest also don't bring
anything you want to be arrested with
yeah
well look look look
i've seen people get wrongfully arrested
at protests and i've seen people get
arrested because the cops can't make a
determination on who's the one's
throwing the molotovs and so they'll
arrest everybody and then sort it out i
don't agree with it always sometimes
like
sometimes it's like okay i don't know i
don't know how you solve the problem but
telling someone i think it's good advice
to turn your cell phone off and turn off
face and touch id because the cop can
take your phone and hold up your face
and then get into it yes and
fourth amendment i'm not a fan
the one thing i'm like i want people to
protest safely i want them to have uh
washcloth and snacks and stuff but they
tell you to bring water for drinking and
tear gas and to wear heat races and
gloves and i'm like sounds like y'all
are getting ready for some violence that
is not a safe protest that's not at
least that's not a protest i would want
to be involved in there's a saying i
wouldn't want to be near any of that the
left likes opposed to meme where they
say
to look who's starting a rock to look at
who is starting a riot look who came
dressed for the riot and they show riot
cops and then i'm just like uh-huh
uh-huh and you're also wearing masks
with heroes and gloves and showing up
with sunglasses and and bricks and bats
and stuff yeah you're you're both the
cops wouldn't be there wearing riot gear
if riders weren't showing up exactly
yeah but they do show up which creates a
precedent and now the police will show
up in riot gear regardless speaking of
aoc she was just arrested this week um
faking being handcuffed well well first
off they were did she have her
heat-resistant gloves when she was
around she did not oh she didn't read
her own crap she didn't she
well they were laying in the street they
were laying across the road the capitol
police asked them three times
congresswoman would you please get out
of the road you make it run over they
refused and so the police were escorting
them out but here's something you guys i
want everyone to know you can go to
cuffthesquad.com
and send aoc or ilhan omar some
handcuffs oh my gosh really so for those
of you for those of you who have no
squad.com they pretended to be
handcuffed
they did they pretended so send her some
see there's her picture now also i want
to point out it was like 93 degrees at
the time
it's very warm it isn't warm wearing a
lot of yeah and she doesn't look sweaty
they're both wearing dark clothing long
non-descript clothing yeah
and a green scarf uh for the group that
george soros funds
interesting yep that was out in the news
today
that it was an org it was an organized
effort with a george soros funded group
uh the green scarves yeah the green
scarf i forget the name of the group but
it's out in the news and um the whole
thing was organized so we
want them to have handcuffs because they
don't have any there when they're faking
their arrests
they need them
if they had their own they could have
taken the cuffs out put them on behind
their own backs their photos would have
been a lot better for their fundraising
emails
it would have been it would have been
seamless just fake blood smeared across
their face this one really this story
really pissed me off it is a raisin and
blatant attempt at they know the media
will protect them
aoc can go on colbert and make up
nonsense about the civil war did you see
that one
no she she
i don't watch stephen colbert you know i
respect it i i have to watch it because
it's like i'm trying to you know she
made an appearance i want to see what
happened right she said the craziest
thing ever and you know i think it was
sheamus who mentioned it was a total
chad move to go on national television
just lie like that he's not wrong but uh
she said
she's like look at what happened in the
civil war the supreme court was passing
rulings that was hindering lincoln's uh
taking out the confederacy taking on the
supreme court was hindering abraham
lincoln like with dred scott which said
that black people couldn't be citizen so
what did abraham lincoln do he passed he
signed the emancipation proclamation
okay
dred scott happened like six was it four
or so years before lincoln became
president the confederacy did not take
over the supreme court the secession
happened before lincoln became president
and the emancipation proclamation was
two years after he became president and
had no effect whatsoever on dred scott
but she just lies the media doesn't do
anything about it so when she faked
having handcuffs on yep and the photos
came out with her hands behind her back
and i saw all the people on facebook and
twitter being like why are they cuffing
her why are they cuffing her i'm like
what a scumbag
i can't stand these people man everyone
should be angry because here's the deal
aoc she she comes from new york new york
has abortion the the women in her
district have full access to abortion
why is she laying in the street and
faking being arrested ilhano moore ilhan
omar they have abortion in minnesota the
women in her district have full access
to abortion i mean it's fake outrage
well and that's the thing it's like
if you
truly believe in your cause you should
be able to argue it without fake
publicity stunts and me as someone who
is pro-choice it's like this just makes
us look stupid i would so much rather
you have a conversation about why than a
publicity stunt for your instagram or
your tick tock or whatever i agree which
and i see we can agree that that's gonna
be the sound bite by the way they use
against me just you looking at me going
i agree and they're gonna be cancelled i
love you james i love you so much um
that's gonna be the same yeah
i did it okay so i do uh he's gonna
regret oh you're far right no no
politics flows in one direction yeah if
a person on the left stand next stands
next to a person on the right it proves
the person on the left is right it's a
right winger yeah we should have a
picture of me and you and then it just
says she becomes progressive why can't
that happen
look at her going to the left if you
i'll stand on the left and you stand on
100 yeah like just i'm i'm thinking of
the math right
if one person
stands next if a person if a progressive
stand next to a conservative people will
be like look at this they're hanging out
with conservatives their right wing but
what if it's one one liberal standing
next to two concer uh two conservatives
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry what if it's a
conservative standing next to two
liberals are both liberals now
conservative
or did the two liberals kidnap the
conservatives or like how many liberals
equals one conservative exactly this is
hollywood so this is this is a bunch of
common core math going on
imagine one conservative guy in the
middle with five antifa around him and
has his arm around their shoulders are
they gonna say those antifa are all
right wing all of them no they're to say
they kidnapped they kidnapped him no oh
absolutely yeah and he fought kidnapped
conservative
so yeah it i don't know point made well
so i
um
uh want to circle back to abortion he
says regardless oh i missed jinsaki
i liked her way better than than karine
yes let's let's do this
actually we actually have a story here
that we can uh we can get into
uh from timcats.com youtube to remove
videos containing false claims and
unsafe instructions regarding abortion
quote we prioritize connecting people to
content from authoritative sources on
health topics now this is interesting
this is censorship about false claims
and unsafe instructions regarding
abortion
is that actually
helping
conservatives no no think about it
the vice magazine vice their website
published an article on taking horse
medicine to induce abortion oh yeah
that's right what cute yes
i thought we're supposed to be against
horses that's what i was going to say
only a pure road
joe rogan says it we are against
horsemen are we against
[Laughter]
so there's a funny meme
and it's called the uh horse it's called
the horseshoe uh medicine theory and
it's uh it's on the right it's
ivermectin on the left it's i forgot
what it's called you guys know what it's
called yeah it's like an antibiotic no
it was like an ant acid or something or
i don't know induces abortion and then
in the middle was bojack horseman but
it's like
vice actually ran that so think about
what's happening right now you've got
red states banning abortion youtube
enacts a censorship policy that's going
to stop progressives and liberals from
giving advice on how to induce abortion
or seek it out in these states
wow so that's actually so maybe
youtube's kind of against the baby
killing or where are we going i think
youtube's always been scared of
liability they should be that's it so
that's why when you get claims from the
right about say vermectin they're like
no shut it down shut it down because
someone would sue them now you've got
progressives who are going to be like
here's how you induce an abortion and
they're like no no shut it down shut it
down
yeah but this is where corporate
communism comes in i'm very much against
censorship so
you know what's really amazing is i
believe in people and i believe in their
intelligence and i believe if you allow
them if they can read as much as they
can and see and see people debate and
argue and share ideas guess what people
are going to figure out the truth so so
let's let's take this
what if youtube didn't censor all that
stuff and they're put and i you know how
pro-life i am and you have them people
putting out stories about how to
self-induce an abortion which i think is
horrific they die
they would die
it's it's awful but then you would also
have people trying to save their lives
on youtube
saying this this will kill you don't do
this it's not going to just kill your
baby it's going to kill you and and you
so i suppose the issue is i mean we
don't want anyone to take a a drug and
and kill themselves and that's horrific
but and that's an extreme example but
when you allow people to debate ideas
instead of cover it up yeah you know
what it's the truth is gonna get
revealed so i totally agree with you on
that free speech point that's why free
speech is so important to debate the
real ideas um i'm still in shock that me
and you went for the same horse joke at
the same time and i'm like damn it now
we are friends um and then the other
thing i really like i'm gonna stop all
the rumors about me jamie this is that
that's my goal
that is my goal that's awesome um the
the other thing i liked that you said
was
the anti-war comment because to me
being truly pro-life is
pro-life if you're if you're pro-life
when it comes to abortion you
in my opinion pro-life is also
anti-death penalty it's anti-war it's
you know all these things it's a stance
on abortion
no no no but like if you're taking it as
a bigger
uh a bigger picture no because i think
that's what about ism because it's like
oh you're pro-life well what about this
social issue i i hold dear to me and
this one and this one and this one and
if you don't agree with me on all of
those
well then you're not pro-life are you
well i take back my one compliment
marjorie uh no i no i i really do think
that like if you take it out of an
abortion context right so you could flip
it the other way it's only in the
abortion context we we at timcast.com
had an editorial meaning and we do not
use to the best of our abilities we uh
refrain from using the terms pro-choice
and pro-life in these in these contexts
because it does not adequately explain
what's happening in many of these
protests so there were a bunch of
protests some people were out there
being like we're pro-choice yeah and
it's like what does that mean because
all that results in is like you got
people who are who were for a vax
mandate and then the inverse argument
happens well if you're really for
pro-choice then you have to support my
right not to take medicaid medication
and the left doesn't do it right and
then the left says well if you were
really pro-life and then i'm like that
doesn't matter right are you for
abortion or do you oppose abortion sure
the the pro-choice group was actually
advocating for the expansion of abortion
and the right group was arguing for the
rescinding of access or i should say a
reduction in access to abortion so we
just say pro and anti-abortion cool i
will rephrase i like that you're
anti-war and i am i am anti-war i like
that a lot and i think a lot of people
on the left probably don't know that
especially as the left is advocating for
war my question on abortion and i mean
this like it's not a gotcha thing like i
legitimately want to know is if abortion
was banned when you were talking about
those youtube videos and obviously women
would get hurt right if they try to
induce their own abortion because you're
watching i can barely learn a song on
guitar watching youtube tutorials let
alone am i going to figure out how to
perform an abortion
which would be awful it would not be
good so my question is i don't want
anybody to do that one should do that
what do you do like what is your
solution for those cases and i i don't
care about percentages let's say it's
one for those case of
a child being rape for the for the case
of incest is what is the answer because
i don't know right what's the answer for
what happens a lot of times with
prohibition where it's still going to
happen but it's going to happen unsafe
like
what do we do about those situations if
because i do believe that you're
pro-life for like i believe that you
well there's a really really simple
argument because we've had this
conversation like 50 billion times
um banning murder you still have murders
so right so if the idea is that an
abortion is wrong and it's a murder and
people decide to go and just try and
commit it in an unsafe way it's like
that's gonna happen no but i i i just
wanna know because you did make that
point about how you want to help women
as well so like what would you do if
abortion was legal to help those women
well tim just made a really good point
we murder is illegal and people are
getting murdered every day
so and we can't we don't have a perfect
world and it's impossible to control
everything and stop anything bad from
happening to anyone we wish we could but
it's impossible right
so
and and a child being raped incest is
wrong all of that stuff are horrific and
occasionally they happen
and so that's why there's some people
have different levels of what they think
is right and wrong for abortion i still
believe in life at conception i really
do
and then on rape
now this is what happens when a woman is
raped and if she goes to the hospital
right away they typically give her a
plan b pill that happens
almost in every single instance when a
woman goes to the hospital and there's
an extensive uh process for the woman to
be treated
so that is like it's such a small
percentage real quick does plan plan b
prevents conception
plan b prevents uh prevents implantation
um and i'm not saying i'm for that i'm
just saying that's what happens when
women are raped are someone informed
that they're given that pill yes they
are informed when they go to the
hospital that they're given that pill
um so just letting you know how rare it
is if a woman is really raped and she
goes to the hospital for it
i think most women are taking it um but
there's also some amazing stories oh my
gosh you meet some of the most beautiful
people and hear their stories that were
born out of rape
and
and and wow those are some strong women
to to give to to have that child
that was born out of a horrible horrible
situation but i will say this
abortion was not legal
until what was it 1973 yeah so imagine
how many people have lived
during the since the beginning of time
because there weren't abortions well and
that's why whenever you get people on
the left who sound like they're
pro-abortion not the safe rare and legal
but just like you know all willy-nilly
about it like i i'm never gonna be on
that
side the reason that the word choice for
me is so important is because
of those rare circumstances you know
what i mean and that's where i just go
it's so hard for me to fully commit over
to the other side when you hear you know
terrible stories about things that
happen to you know kids and then you
just go ah i don't know it's so hard
it's so hard i i
i think it's absolutely insane that
we've gotten to the point where there's
advocacy for
uh post-viability abortion
because oh yeah elective contraceptive
post-viability abortion to me just
sounds like
insane it is insane you mean you can
deliver the baby it can be c-section you
can induce labor and the baby can live
but you want to kill it anyway uh that's
just i'm sorry oh it's too much it's
it's it's it's like it's such a thing
you can't even comprehend it but really
you you to i think we forgot i think so
many people have forgotten that before
1973 there was an abortion and and we've
over 63 million people have been killed
in the womb and you have to ask who are
those people who would they have been
isn't it how would of our how would our
society be different if they were here
with us what if they were all the bad
people uh
five times more likely to be black
i believe i believe it's five times more
like truly black genocide it's
absolutely insane to me and just awful
the way that you can have the
conversation i think is so important
where it's just we are lacking empathy
right
it's either you are
pro-women dying or pro-babies dying if
you just look at it on twitter or
facebook or whatever and i think just
having that second when you hear a story
and this is with all issues not even
just abortion when there's a school
shooting
everyone i we don't live in a world
anymore where when a tragedy happens we
can all
take a deep breath and actually feel
empathy for the people who were actually
hurt or for the woman who was raped or
for you know all these stories we
immediately have to go what is our side
saying how can we blame the republicans
how can we blame the democrats and
that's where i think we're losing our
soul i gotta tell you you know as
someone who's been traditionally liberal
and pro-choice i do not see that from
the right i see no i'm saying in general
but but i don't i don't hear uh it's the
democrats fault how can we blame them i
hear you like like i put you know what
let me see if i can pull something up on
instagram yeah let me let me pull up the
old tim cast instagram i think was the
last thing i posted
all right is it going to give me the
business let's see if i can uh
i'll get it all right here we go take a
look at this okay let's go so
we show this all the time the ground
news bias mine is is left leaning but
there's a thirty percent right
uh anger sargon of newsweek actually
more right wing than left wing and then
we have ben shapiro 39 left 48 right and
then you have the nbc news team just all
completely left i don't hear that
when it's like there's an argument
happening the right says
guys let's let's figure this out let's
compromise and the left just says you're
far right and crazy and i won't listen
to you especially after roe was
overturned think about all of these
pro-life advocacy groups and crisis
pregnancy centers that were getting
targeted after that
i feel like that's all being perpetrated
by the left and by pro-abortionists when
elizabeth warren wants to to shut down
yeah they want to literally ban this is
a senator she thinks they don't have the
right to exist in these pregnancy
resource centers run by women the entire
pro-life to help women by women for free
women and for free i volunteered at one
of them and they had fake appointments
booked all the time by these
pro-choicers who wanted to sabotage the
purpose of that place which is all
volunteer-based so by the way can i tell
you
as uh
a dude
on the left
what i heard about those places so i
know nothing about those places straight
up like i i would ask you who worked
there um but what we heard on the left
all i knew
was essentially oh those are the places
that trick girls who want to get
abortions and pressure them into having
the baby that's like the talking point
there's nothing that i've got no no but
like that's yeah they like give
carriages and like formula and they help
them sign up for government services
free ultrasound free ultrasound free
resources free counseling the counseling
monsters as framed as like we're going
to trick you into not getting an
abortion there are plenty of clients who
walked out all the time saying like no i
think i'm still going to get an abortion
and they were like okay and then you
tied them down and we love you and
you know
like we can't stop you but like we can't
stop you but we can lock these doors
they were like we
[Laughter]
no but i mean but but this is what i'm
talking about right where it's like
and i'm sure by the way
there are pro-choice people who would
make points i hope about sex education
or about things like that that maybe you
guys would agree with or maybe pro-life
people would agree with and when i hear
what those centers really are i go okay
man well i guess i was wrong about that
and i just wish we could have more
conversations like this where it's like
the goal should be less suffering period
whether that's for babies whether that's
for women and then you take people who
disagree and you go how do we get this i
agree and you want to know something yes
i enjoy you being in this conversation
because i think men should be in the
conversation because you want to know
something being a father is also so
important what and why don't men get a
sense think about the choices why has it
taken me since 40 years old to hang out
with conservative women this rules
that's right i am important you guys
hear that follow me on twitter okay
well i wonder if uh a lot of what we see
with you know look it's like two-thirds
seventy percent of millennial females
are democrat voters so i wonder how many
of those guys are just like whatever you
say i'll say whatever i have to say to
hook up with you right i don't know but
i passed by a whole table full of them
last night was in a restaurant
and i have to tell you i gotta tell you
guys what happened
so we're in this restaurant
we got there they had little american
flags on the sidewalk i was like i think
i'm gonna be safe here
so
we're hanging out have a great time but
we're walking out and we're walking by
the patio and there's a large table of
yeah millennial-aged women
and what tipped you off to them was
there when you saw them were you like oh
no i wasn't like oh it was they were
like
and they're like ugh she's horrible oh
my god i can't believe that's mtg
and i was like oh boy here we go and
then they started they were throwing the
names and making the comments so i just
turned around to him and i said hey
thanks for voting for biden
our the inflation it's great gas prices
i can't afford them thank you guys are
doing awesome your president he's the
best you guys did great and they were
like ah they're yelling at me and i said
i hope you all have babies i hope you
all have babies i can't wait you should
be a mom everybody be a mother have a
baby
and then i left and then oh that they
were unglued the fact that your heckle
line is i hope you have a baby is so
funny to me it's what hits home for
those women the most right city living
late i just want to write a blog i don't
want to have a baby
no i just want them to be happy oh
they're so bitter because they they but
think about how they're targeted though
they they were encouraged to have a
career
and then the company they work for is
probably some corporation or a big one
like the federal government because it
was in washington dc oh boy yeah and but
think about this what are what are
corporations doing right now paying for
abortions abortion vacation
parental leave too yeah but you want to
know what's more difficult for the
employer
that that that maternity leave yeah yeah
dealing with those them missing to go to
all their doctors appointments so we we
uh a couple of things one is apparently
companies that are doing are getting
sued because men say it's a
discriminatory practice to offer a
benefit to only females yeah but uh oh
yeah i should get a vacation just to
knock people down no no no the idea is
this is gonna try to balance a guy
jamie sorry sorry a guy should be able
to go to the company and say i think i
got a woman pregnant and she needs an
abortion so pay for it and they should
have to do that as well
otherwise it's a discriminatory practice
to only pay for abortion services for
female employees so are you into
depopulation is that what's going on
here this sounds very world economically
here at tim cast
we will not pay for our female employees
abortions we will give them unlimited
maternity and paternity leave for the
men because we trust the people who work
here legitimately want to work here and
if they need time with their children
they're allowed to have it all right
well i guess that l.a trip i told you
about next week is off
well i'm not paying for abortion
services but if you have a kid go take
care of your kid and we'll let us know
when you're when you're good so uh it's
like we have a big company but we do
have you know a lot of employees and
then family issues have come up and i'm
like take as much time as you need
i i trust that the job you do is
something you're passionate about and if
you're not then maybe you shouldn't be
here anyway so just go do your thing and
then we'll figure it out and then
if we don't hear from him for a couple
weeks i'll be like how are you how's it
going let us know when you're ready
i think you know maybe it's too trusting
a lot of big corporations don't want to
do that because they don't trust their
employees and a lot of employees
probably would would exploit that but
i don't know i will say stupid the care
you have for
us is insane
that's very he he also i i will also say
he doesn't take compliments well um
don't get mushy don't you tell me i care
about my um oh my god
[Applause]
he only locked you in there for nine
months yeah nine months yeah that was
that was the rule uh i i i give you
bacon tim tim will text me like really
good news like hey we're going to do
this and i will write him the sappiest
response where i'm just like this has
been a dream of mine and i've been
through so much and then his response is
just like she had five i'm like all
right
okay okay there's a lot of that it's a
lot of that we're having a love fest
here tonight everybody's everybody's all
sweet all right so let's talk about
what's happening on the january 6th
what a segway yeah everyone's all sweet
january 6. well it's time to spice it up
come on yeah
heart cam hearts well what's going on
january 6 so they had an 8 o'clock prime
time hearing tonight which is i'm sure
already started and it was all about the
one it's supposed to be about the 187
minutes
that trump did nothing uh to stop the
riot oh okay that's what it's about
but so i brought my notes because i had
to had to make notes for this
would you say that uh uh let me preface
this yeah i'll ask you a question the
way a cnn reporter would ask the white
house practice press secretary
they would say um
congresswoman we know for a fact that
the january 6 committee lies
they lie often and they smear innocent
people notably this is cnn no no
yeah so so well how they would ask the
question right okay so so we know that
the democrats and the january 6
committee are lying about everything um
can you comment
oh
well that doesn't sound like cnn because
well no no no no no but they do the
inverse of that they'll say okay they'll
go out and they'll they'll give the
answer to the question to the person not
normally how they talk to me but
they'll say they'll say uh we know that
donald trump committed these crimes in
these crimes um uh so thank you for your
time and they'll sit down oh yeah there
it is and then they just flow in to give
all the information they
they they they present the uh the answer
in their question for the the white
house yes absolutely so yeah
well you have to do that for karine
uh because she she needs that help they
they have to she's really bad at this
this is like she's terrible jen seki was
actually a good spin doctor she was
great yeah like the she she was a good
spin doctor karine is just like someone
asked a question about biden doing
something horrible and she'll go oh he
did yeah she's like she's like flipping
through the book
yeah
they're going the plausible deniability
route they're like don't tell her
anything because then she can't get
caught in a lie
so i mean what would you do if you were
her i would run off stage every day
crying so but in all seriousness though
look uh i'm obviously bitter because
jamie raskin included me to defame me in
his evidence but uh so so tell us what's
going on and and what's happening with
these these current lies well i think
that what they're missing is
someone that's really important to the
entire day and that's ray epps they want
to blame president trump they want to
say that he caused it he told people to
do it but you know raps is on camera
telling people to do it literally
january 5th he's on video telling people
to go
in
to the capitol can i just can i just uh
to get personal
they include a clip of me reading a fox
news article and and claim that was me
promoting trump's protest and they not
once have shown right ups literally
telling people to storm the capitol no
but they showed you so they they
slandered you
and they made you as if you were part of
of organizing
this this event that's supposed to be
the worst day in america these are evil
people yeah you should sue them you
can't speech and debate clause oh yeah
speech and debate that's right
yeah maybe we should bring you in tim
when we get our turn when republicans
take back the house well i can certainly
talk to that and be like here's a video
of me reading a news article and then
them accusing me of yeah we should give
you the opportunity to set the record
straight because that's not fair i mean
how many times have you guys been
swatted i'm sure that people think that
you're somehow part of some crazy
insurrection or something i i think
there are a lot of people who um
you know jamie was saying this it's the
it's the democrat version of the fox
news dad i guess you called it yeah it's
it's it's the people who turn on cnn cnn
and msnbc and then sit there with their
eyes glazed in their drool point out of
their mouth and they just believe
everything uncritically without
challenging it
yeah and then they're they're they live
in the conspiracy and we still they
believed jesse smilet
and and were supposed to they're holding
a panel together
and they're the people who believe jesus
is like come on they can't govern i mean
are you nuts people forget the rise of
fox news
happened after september 11th
and
msnbc was
you know had had anti-war voices on like
phil donahue right and immediately when
fox news became popular and they go okay
we need american flags we need patriotic
music we can't have any war and suddenly
you know the only debates you saw
against the war it would be like a
five-star general on the right and then
on the left it would be like janine
garofalo like it would just be like
these like terrible just like smash
debates to make the anti-war left just
look like a couple actors right right
and so then msnbc and cnn they had to
play catch-up because fox news was
getting all the ratings was just
smashing them and so then they became uh
you know at first they sort of became
the the adversaries for fox news and
then
when i would say like probably when like
obama got elected they just became okay
now we're not necessarily
gonna push back now we're just just
party lines whatever that is but it was
the exact same tactics the exact same
music the exact same big personalities
the exact same stifling dissent blah
blah blah blah blah
all the networks do it now it's the same
but we're so used to because fox news
was first we're so used to just going ah
fox news oh that's classic fox news fox
news but what we don't realize on the
left is no no no msnbc
they're hard left
they've all done it i wouldn't say look
msnbc is crackpot conspiracy nonsense
big time fox news has some like
you you with fox news you've gotten a
bit of tucker carlson being like where's
ray epps what does this mean and the
media comes out and says he's a
conspiracy theorist for bringing up
right apps attacking him no he's not but
on msnbc they entertained rachel maddow
was like russia russia russia russia
russia for three years she nearly cried
when the mueller report came out that
trump didn't do it it's crazy remember
you see that video she's like
it's like wow your whole life is
breaking in front of your face maybe you
should have actually done research
instead of just lying yeah but the thing
is is is really a lot of news doesn't
represent regular people and how we
think so i've been a republican all my
life but when
when we went into iraq looking for
weapons of mass destruction
i was sitting here going why are we
going in iraq they were from saudi
arabia the 19 terrorists and then i'm
like well where's the weapons of mass
destruction did you ever find any
no no so everybody's going like what are
we doing i i mean i asked those
questions what are we doing that i hated
it the whole time and this is people got
so divided because i remember any time i
criticized the war even from the left
they would go you're anti-troop and what
i always explained is anti-military that
is a pro-military that is that
pro-military and pro-america i don't
want you yes die because some
politicians don't know what they're
doing they're doing that especially when
they come home and they're not treating
ptsd and they're not getting the
benefits they deserve it's like being
anti and they're missing
how about how about my favorite uh when
barack obama drone bombed a 16 year old
american kid i mean it's just the obama
administration they called him obama
it's amazing they called him the
deporter in chief
i pulled this up on my segment earlier
today because we have we have other news
too we'll get into a second that joe
biden's approval rating
aggregate is lower than trump's lowest
point so biden has broken the record
this is the most popular he's number one
well history he's number one i want to
put attack on that but so i was looking
at uh news
obama was 42 positive coverage 20
negative
and he literally executed an american
citizen without charge or trial the
media is
derelict in this country absolutely
during
during remember when the only scandal in
this country was a tan suit
i remember when he killed a kid
now uh
now the media has gone beyond derelict
and now they're complicit now they're
actively engaging in the psyops and the
manipulation of the american people to
defend criminals they are biden for
instance absolutely
both of them so i haven't introduced
articles of impeachment over and over
and over so excited when we brought
about invited you lit up in your chair
that was great can't believe it you want
to know something i have to tell y'all
something
remember the iphone leak that just
happened recently
iphone and icloud i think both right yes
someone it was in the middle of the
night someone sent me a telegram channel
and people had loaded that thing up with
contents of his icloud and iphone and i
saw things that i i wish they're like
nightmares in my head now i'm not
kidding you the man was always naked
sure um had sex with i i don't know how
many women
i uh women of the night
all kinds of women but yeah but there's
there's several videos that i
cannot get over and this is where it's
so
upsetting this was like your clockwork
orange
they were and i you know they were
probably 14 to 15 years old whoa
but is that all confirmed
that is me what i saw with my eyes and
making my own judgment i can't confirm
it you gotta you gotta just give all the
i'd say give to the fbi but i'm not no
you want to know what happened
while i was going through the horrific
things and i'll tell you there was a
picture of a boy in a bathtub
that had to be
pre-teen somewhere in the early teens
preteen and we don't know if these are
real no i they're they looked 100 real
they were from but while i was going
through it the entire channel got
wiped clean everything disappeared
and was that telegram that did that
i don't know i can't tell you to this
day now i would never have saved any of
that stuff on my phone you want to know
why you'll get in trouble yes it's
illegal i remember people posting that
and it was like publicly available i
didn't click on it because i knew it
yeah it's horrible stuff it's horrible
stuff i feel like the the crack and the
prostitutes and everything like that is
just a distraction from the political
corruption though right yeah well
doesn't the drug use actually make
hunter biden more human like you
actually feel sorry for him because
drugs are horrible
drugs are horrible and they do horrible
things to people but having sex with
minors of course no no that's illegal
but then people focus on one thing
they're like you're degrading this
person for having a drug problem and
like yeah then it's just do you know how
many people have seen all that people
empower people with positions that can
do something about it and no one does
anything
it's it's that is that's the part that i
can't take but there's even more to it
there's the same way there's that kind
of content there's also information on
business deals and banking information
and with foreign countries and this is
the president of the united states son
the and joe says that hunter is the
smartest guy he knows like
why are we all in this situation that is
my question is that as an american why
as american citizens why are we all in
this situation
and and why does why does our media
protect it well let's jump to this uh
big news
ladies and gentlemen it is a historic
day today
the latest quinnipiac poll came out
showing joe biden's approval ratings at
31
when you add this to the latest
aggregate numbers
joe biden's approval rating right now
in our the real clear politics average
is 36.8
add in the 31 and it drops down to 36.2
it is a historic day because donald
trump's lowest point was 37.1 that's
right
joe biden or is it 30 it's 37.0 sorry i
thought it was 0.1 37 is the lowest
point
joe biden's approval rating right now in
aggregate all of the polls combined is
lower than the lowest point trump ever
experienced in his presidency
this means objectively
historical record
joe biden is to the american people a
worse president than trump wow now i
think the thing about trump is i
actually think trump was one of the best
presidents we've had
you look at the economic indicators
in 2018 when uh he when when democrats
want a bunch of seats
really great economy jim cramer of all
people best numbers of our lives a lot
of good things from donald trump now you
can talk about decorum fine joe biden
across the board inability to speak no
decorum sniffing children no decorum i
will take trump being a potty mouth and
i'll say yeah yeah yeah yeah but then
joe biden sniffs kids then he destroys
the economy he presides over one of the
worst economies in the history of this
country record inflation record soaring
gas prices hype it's just food shortages
are coming war in eastern europe
the surrender of afghanistan
no question even with donald trump
according to pew only receiving around
five percent positive coverage
he still is now objectively paulie has
pulled better than biden did
isn't that something that has got to go
unreal and it's only been
he's got to be impeached he does he
needs to be impeached do you think
you'll be able to impeach him when you
guys win in november i think it's
unforgivable to not impeach him
that's how i feel and i think i think
the american people feel this way and i
think it's imp so i believe in
accountability i you know i think if
someone is doing a bad job or they're
intentionally doing a bad job or they're
not fit for the job you have to fire
them and you have to replace them with
someone that can do a better job and
right now we are in a crisis and i'm
going to go off because they impeached
trump twice and what did trump do for us
the abraham accords historic amazing
peace in the middle east coming what did
he do in peace in the whole world he he
met with kim jong-un and he was mocked
for it and he entered enemy territory
with no security detail one of the most
tremendous things i've seen a president
do in my lifetime and with having family
going back to uh my i believe my great
my maybe my great grandfather
was uh our great i think my great
grandfather yeah actually was uh uh from
the north
there was no north of the time
so the country splits and i actually got
to go and visit seoul and see like you
know learn you know try and see like
where my family come from what cities
are they from you know having a family
that came from outside of the us it's a
really interesting thing then i hear
donald trump he's like i want peace i
want to end this conflict i'm like how
amazing would that be and he crosses the
dmz
walks into enemy territory
after all the threats and all the fear
and all the saber rattling they could
have just taken him right there and held
him hostage in anything and they didn't
they didn't do it trump was tremendously
brave for doing that trump had done such
great things on foreign policy he was
getting our troops out of the middle
east he was setting a timeline for
getting out of afghanistan joe biden
screwed that up they impeached him twice
and he did some of the greatest things
i've ever seen as someone who is just
livid over the lives of obama and his
foreign policy to see the tremendous
foreign policy of donald trump that's
right the domestic policy was incredible
as well bringing back manufacturing it's
a great economy but oh i can admit it i
didn't like the way he his attitude but
it didn't matter in the long run yeah
school choice opposing critical race
theory and government contracting good
foreign policy this is a guy who needed
another term and he needs another one
now i uh i thought the worst thing that
was going to happen to me was becoming
pals with marjorie the worst thing is
tim making me like trump for five
minutes
look i said
that north korea stuff i've never heard
phrase like that and i was like that's
like that's kind of badass it is and i
was i was so angry when they were like
he's pawning up to dictators and i'm
like that's what i heard they could have
killed him yeah he went to nor he went
there and have you seen the videos of
the north korean soldiers trying to
steal the south korean soldiers or the
people trying to flee north korea
getting shot and killed by the north
korean soldiers
and donald trump was like let me walk in
here yeah dude dennis rodman at least
looks like he can take them physically
trump couldn't even run away if they
wanted to i was i almost cried when i
saw him do it was amazing i was just
thinking to myself like an american
president foregoing security
standing next to enemy soldiers we are
still at war the war never ended and i
was just like wow man yo someone tweeted
me that incredible youtube video and
then also put like the 24 theme song
over it and i'll watch that tonight it's
a meme they did the meme they did kim
jong-un has a skateboard yeah he's like
he's like gesturing
are you serious this is great it's
really cool you know he also moved the
american embassy to jerusalem yeah i
don't know that was i thought that was
incredible i really did it was
incredible he pulled us out of that iran
deal
which which the biden administration is
trying to get back into it right now
it's like everything we it's really
obama's third term right it's obama's
third term and joe biden has no idea
what's going on the abraham accords
that planes would be flying from israel
over over uh islamic countries that
commerce would start and what i heard
from the former anti-war left supposedly
the current one is they go yeah well
everyone knows they're all secretly
working together anyway and i was like
are you kidding you couldn't fly from
one country to the other you couldn't
enter one country if you had a stamp
from israel now you can now you can
that's right i'm just you know
donald trump tried getting our troops
out of i think syria was and the the
officials lied about how many troops
were in there because the war machine
will not even even listen to the
president and what happens when biden
gets in he botches and surrenders
afghanistan burns it burns everything on
the ground
let me tell you something tim this is
why they hate
president trump
because he wasn't controlled by the
state department and why is it that uh
vladimir putin didn't invade ukraine why
why the conflict had simmered down under
donald trump
it's because donald trump was actually
lowering tensions globally it's
remarkable he created relationships with
people like vladimir putin with kim
jong-un he created relationships and
that created peace but they want the war
they love the war the
military-industrial complex they can't
have donald trump yeah i've been voting
no on this garbage ever since it started
no they want it and i've been amazed i'm
shocked by it remember when it's not
saving anyone's life it's killing more
people trump fired 59 tomahawk missiles
into syria
me uh i get mad a bunch of the populist
right people are like like what is he
doing
and then the media is like is this
trump's truly presidential moment yeah
that's how they see the world isn't it
well it's it's it's something to behold
but what's happening in ukraine
should severely concern everyone it
really should and i'll tell you why
it's we don't belong there we're
neglecting our own border we're
neglecting our own people our our
economy is falling apart inflation's out
of control
democrats are literally destroying
energy fossil fuel industries they want
to completely wipe them out
and it will kill people we have we we
have become a great nation based on
fossil fuels we have we have air
conditioning we have we have heat in the
winter time don't you use air
conditioning against me oh yeah i know i
know i love it so much i do too i i love
air conditioning and refrigerators we
can store food i mean these are all
amazing things in it and it became
possible through fossil fuel energies
but the democrats want to take it away
because they're saying that carbon is
the problem well i think there has to be
i think there's to be a middle ground
right because you've said
we've gotten a lot from fossil fuels and
just like you were talking about you
know abortion was only became legal in
the in the 1970s it's like okay so some
things from the past are also bad right
like we also used to have slaves we also
used to not have uh polio vaccines we
also used to look like
cast members of the oregon trail um but
i think acknowledging that it's like
yeah some some stuff we use in excess uh
is hurting the environment what is that
how can we
come up with alternatives for that while
also
not going the complete
lefty route like throw it all out you
know what i mean let it be market driven
and and here's the thing so we can't
rely on on wind turbines right now that
remember they froze in texas and now i
was in that storm by the way
i had i lived in austin for like three
weeks and i was like ah texas is great
and then suddenly you had to like
sophie's choice
yeah oh yeah oh that's what it was a
hundred percent i was like this isn't
what everyone's talking about it's just
a bunch of hipsters and joe rogan uh it
was wonderful and breakfast tacos uh and
then yeah within three weeks that storm
happened and you suddenly have to like i
i was like
dumping chlorine pool water into the
back of my toilet so i could like
attempt to flush it and wow none of us
had like it was totally it was crazy so
that's a failure we can't rely on that
energy it's the the it's not there yet
and i'm i'm not a fan of those things i
think they're gigantic and ugly and then
we have solar panels overheating right
now they can't provide enough
electricity and we have china and other
countries moving back to coal so what do
you mean real quick we do have a big a
bit of a breaking story that i want to
get to in a second but i want so i still
want to ask one quick question before we
move on is uh
who do you think for 2024 you think i
mean obviously trump's running president
trump's running he's running so you're
you're true he just hasn't said it yet
well we just talked about all the great
reasons to have him as president right
yeah i mean for me i mean foreign policy
has always been one of the biggest
issues for me that you know
we have to
the sacrifice of of americans uh of the
bravest american men and women for
corporate bs
look at where we are right now
especially in the world where we are
right now we're in a dangerous place
we we are actively fighting a proxy war
with a nuclear country russia
that that is dangerous uh but just
i'm curious your thoughts on desantis
because he's the name that's popped up i
think desantis is fantastic i really do
but i would i'm a little selfish i would
love to have president trump for four
years and then i went to santos for
eight what about trump i want 12. what
about trump desantis for four years and
then the santa's for eight years they
can't though right because they're from
the same state and a president and a
vice president yep
president and vice president cannot be
from the same state you and your
conspiracies i know
that's true
so if he moved his residence to new
jersey
he's in new jersey right now isn't he
yeah
what if he says i'm a resident of new
jersey now then what if that's why
they said aren't they doing construction
on mar-a-lago or something i don't know
what a convenience store
you know something
look on your face lock the doors lock
the doors no i'm just enjoying listening
to you guys i think we're gonna see a
lot of people run
you're gonna see um oh my goodness we've
got nikki haley probably mike pence who
else is going to run christine christie
gnome maybe oh wow good yeah there's
going to be there's going to be a lot of
people running and then obviously on the
democrat ticket there's going to be a
lot of people running too yeah but no
one with any
i can't wait for gavin newsom it's gonna
be so much fun oh he's the worst
do democrats like him no i don't know
right he's awful let me tell you the
dark horse then i don't think he's
running but it would put a it would make
it hard for republicans um
but they hate them they would never do
it is joe manchin if joe manchin
yeah think about that
we have some breaking news that happened
about an hour ago that i want to talk
about
so uh lee zeldin yeah he's a he's a
republican rep i believe he's right yeah
and he's running he's running in new
york for the governor someone just tried
to kill him yeah what
someone tried to stab him
and uh he's he's fine uh nobody got hurt
oh thank god he finished the speech
finish his speech you love to see it
that's pretty badass okay that way was
that a teddy roosevelt thing what was it
roosevelt
shot and he was like i have more to say
yeah that's awesome
and they arrested the person
um i'm just seeing this on twitter uh
after speaking on bail from someone just
tried stabbing new york governor
candidate lee zeldin unreal news 10 nbc
new york post i'm not sure are we seeing
more from this i i this
oh man
that's gonna work let's let's can we get
some is there any more confirmation on
this i want to be very careful here i'm
saying from will chamberlain whom i
trust
implicitly but i don't have further
facts it is it's so breaking it's still
only on twitter but i'm sure they'll
have news i bet post millennial has
it could be some random person posting
some random nonsense
you know
we're waiting for some official
confirmation
uh but i don't i don't know if i see
anything
other than some real media people just
posting a photo wow so i want to make
sure we have uh you know confirmation on
this for sure yeah
oh okay here we go looks like we've got
rochester first
uh okay there's our we got confirmation
zelda attacked at parenting campaign
stop confirmed confirmed
um let's see he was attacked at a
campaign event witness say he was giving
a speech about bail reform when a man
got on stage started yelling wrestled
with a bit pulled out of blade
the alleged attacker was suppressed by
am vets national director joe chenely
whoa a witness with zelda after they
texted zeldin was not hurt and took the
stage again when it was over bravo good
sir
now uh scary and disgusting yes that's
terrifying
horrible unbelievable
yeah thank god he's okay absolutely and
um
and he stood stood up and gave his
speech and i man mad respect okay i i
got some questions marjorie okay
what is the balance right so this
conversation great we're talking about
bringing people together we see what
happens when extreme rhetoric i mean
this guy could just be not even
political he could just be mentally
unhinged we have no idea the story's
just coming in but obviously there's
toxic elements on
both sides right now on both extremes
apparently you've said some
controversial things right and we were
talking about this before
where
it it's what gets attention on issues
right
but what is that line between like would
you get as much attention if you were
like hey i'm just trying to bring people
together
blah blah blah the war is bad i agree
with the left here's i'm pro-life i
agree with the right etc
or
like you were saying you know before we
went on air you were talking about
sometimes this extreme rhetoric is what
gets attention but is the extreme
rhetoric also what leads to like
bombastic is maybe a better word
bombastic yeah yeah i'll take that i can
i'm very direct
you are you don't have much of a filter
as they say well i think that if we're
going to solve problems you have to
really get down to what the what the
issue is yeah do you have an example
um yeah i don't even know if i'm allowed
to say it without getting booted off
youtube but uh uh after show
after show on saturday sign up for the
after show well j okay so so there's an
uh so here's an example okay um i don't
like nancy pelosi and maybe this is the
daily show taken out of context you can
correct me i don't like nancy pelosi i
don't think a lot of people like nancy
pelosi i wonder if that's why her
husband drinks uh i don't know i don't
know
um
but
wasn't there a clip and this stupid
daily show thing i watched uh where you
were like
it's treason and treason you get uh uh
killed or something like that implying
and what everyone said was you were
implying nancy pelosi should be killed
because nancy pelosi committed treason
and the punishment for treason is death
right could that be extreme rhetoric
that would be good that would be the
extreme punishment but there's also
prison right that's not the one you said
no i didn't i didn't call for her to be
killed no i know you didn't call but
even by by using like there are so many
things i do think it's i do think people
who are elected and hold and we swear an
oath and we we're to defend the
constitution we are supposed to uphold
the law 100 and nancy pelosi
and and and i'll say joe biden and and
many others
that will not secure our border right i
believe that is committing treason
because they are they are allowing an
invasion into our country
and it's breaking our laws and they are
they're encouraging it they're turning
their back on it and they're just
washing their hands of it at the same
time nancy pelosi and all the democrats
that want sanctuary cities where they're
people that broke laws to come into our
country
when do we acknowledge that these
elected leaders that swore an oath
to uphold our constitution our lives
what do we call this what do we call it
actually i call it treason
that's a good point i think legally
treason is providing aid uh aid and
comfort to enemies so but enemies have
to be declared by congress i'm pretty
sure if it was like an isis sanctuary
city in delaware
look
there is a very serious problem that um
i would say the cartels are our enemies
i i agree we don't call them our enemies
and they are enabling and making this
happen it's human trafficking yeah on a
scale you've never seen before
and they also work inside our country
the cartels since biden the biden has
taken over
they have they have moved into our
country this is what we've been told
when i went on my border trip and they
are actually they are there's a massive
network in our country did you know
obama gave him guns
yeah the fast and the furious program
you know there is that's right they gave
yeah they gave guns to cartels so uh
good point i think if you're if you're
probably i'm not calling for the death
penalty of anyone but but i think the
american people deserve better but
i want to address uh i want to edit this
uh
people people don't understand what we
hear a lot from like tucker carlson and
people on the right is that the
democrats are bringing in illegal
immigrants so they can vote for them and
then the left says they can't vote
that's wrong
and both sides are wrong
when california brings in a million
illegal immigrants and refuses to abide
by federal law they get an extra
electoral college vote this gives
california an extra congressional seat
which gives them more power to vote in
congress that is subversion so perhaps a
seditious conspiracy i suppose to steal
power from the other states in the union
to be fair i don't even think illegal
immigrants want to move to california
right now they they get free health care
no 126. so uh or there's some kind of
program like that so this is the issue
right this is why trump wanted the
citizenship question because sanctuary
states like california know they get
extra seats so they've recently lost new
york lost one because people are fleeing
but i believe that's the real game plan
you bring them in right before a census
as many as you can you do the census
you're gonna get extra votes for the
presidential election so illegal
immigrants don't vote personally but
that extra congressional seat that's a
solid vote and we're talking about 538
so that is a huge huge advantage one or
two extra votes
at what point
are you going to see a state like texas
say
what they are doing by not abiding by
federal law is subverting
now what did we see in the first civil
war it was the fugitive slave act the
south said we have a federal law if a
slave escapes to the north the north has
to return them and the north said no we
won't now interestingly i mean i agree
the north shore
right they should not have been doing
that they should have been saying no
some things are just morally abhorrent
think about where that brings us today
what happens when they when the
republicans pass a federal law saying if
a woman
takes a viable pr is pregnant with a
viable baby and flees to a state for an
abortion the state must return to the
state of residence and they say no
all of a sudden now you're going to be
entering the same territory when texas
says california is violating federal law
for political power we say no
at what point to your point is someone
going to say we demand the politician
subverting this country be held
accountable and what form does that take
i think impeachment i think nancy pelosi
should not be allowed to run i think she
forfeits office and then we can bring in
whoever else who might run the district
and you know what maybe even might be
more progressive than she is don't no
don't care vote forever you want san
francisco but get the corruption out of
there
no it's correct we have to hold people
accountable because
we're we are falling apart
we're falling apart and it that's every
single that affects everybody yeah even
like there's a bunch of people that
don't even vote could care less
and and they're losing for sure yeah he
did
he did yep a lot of first-time voters he
absolutely but um you know i'm one i'll
attack the republicans
sometimes more than i attack the
democrats because i feel like
republicans have have let me down so
many times
i didn't even vote for mitt romney i
couldn't even vote i was like i can't
vote for this guy
i mean yeah i know one yeah and i didn't
want barack obama my goodness but i
didn't definitely did not want mitt
romney that romney thing is one more
point for our friendship buddy um
it's kind of crazy because i voted for
trump in 2020 but not 2016. yeah but
after seeing what he did
if i could go back in time i'd vote for
him in 2016. oh yeah i was all in
i was unapologetically all in like
ridiculously all in for president trump
and i still am i love the guy absolutely
love him is he perfect no but you want
to know something as messy as our world
is and as screwed up as our country is i
want to put the meanest toughest most
successful proven leader in there to fix
it for us all and i think that's what we
need i don't understand why he's not the
preferred candidate of antifa if they
really think that he has this
destabilizing force who's going to go in
and just gut the country they should be
voting for him being like oh no oh no
it's trump
right
they have this believe it's like he the
the democrats are like he's he's
dismantling our government once upon a
time he's firing people then antifa
should be like yeah
actually they should but the fight the
system antifa were also the same ones to
put mask on and and get out there and
riot for the vaccines yeah it was crazy
watching the video of them attacking
people outside of uh
like antifa attacked an anti-censorship
rally and i'm like what
are you pro-corporate
these are people purchasing corporations
then you have people protesting
processing outside of a facility against
mandated vaccines of vaccine mandates
and antifa attacks them too and i'm like
they're opposing government authority
yeah then i love the memes where they're
like
you know aoc saying the supreme court
shouldn't have the jurisdiction over uh
abortion and it's like okay they
literally ruled that like you agree with
them they said they were sending
authority and giving back to the states
and then but aoc wants jurisdiction
transferred to a different federal court
anyway yeah she just wants to completely
take apart the supreme court packing the
court it's fascist to pack the court i i
love i love the the ban the guns
democrats leftists like real ones they
like guns there's like the social
socialist rifle association for instance
i think ones that hate me love guns they
love guns so much they called they
called my husband and left a voicemail
on his cell phone this past weekend and
said a lot of nasty things about me and
said this is what i'm going to do to
your wife and then they [ __ ] their gun
and fired it several times i told you i
was sorry about that voice my mom
i said i don't know i had to say it on
air i told you before um yeah that's
horrible man i'm sorry that happened
like whenever i
whenever i see people on the right
be attacked with some of the tactics
that i used to criticize on the other
side like i always want to just be like
man that doesn't represent me at all
like that's awful it's awful but how how
often have you heard the left say
respect the diversity of tactics right
that that's a code word for when you see
people getting violent don't try and
stop them or criticize them what
they call it respecting the diversity of
tactics it's a it's a a what does that
even mean well i remember what happened
we used to like get in trouble
anyone who talked about you know when
protests got violent even around occupy
if someone brought up martin luther king
jr
that'd be like oh that's like a a a
sell-out it was a sell-out tactic if you
brought up martin luther king jr and
you'd say you know oh he believed in
peaceful protest blah blah blah blah um
they would all they would almost say
that now it is ridiculous when even this
year you see like the fbi posting like
martin luther king day uh tweets and
stuff you're like okay that's a little
ridiculous but i i i think that having
him as a role model is certainly not a
bad thing and shouldn't be labeled as a
bad thing
so the diversity of tactics thing just
to clarify the idea is that when we
protest a bunch of people will try
different things
and so if so whenever someone would show
up wearing all black and throw bricks
the organizers would say well we respect
a diversity of tactics what yeah it's
not violence it's breaking the law yeah
it's wrong there should be no respect
for that regardless and just like you
said you get more mad at republicans
sometimes yeah i feel like the left
should get really mad at that because
that derails
you know if you're throwing bricks
through windows now the story becomes
bricks through windows not
was this man murdered by the police and
it's like we don't want to take away
from that we if you actually care about
the problem if you want to fix
institutional racism if you want to hold
bad cops accountable and help good cops
you shouldn't be throwing bricks through
windows you should be actually making
your point be out in the streets yeah
peacefully protest um wear your heat
resistant gloves always wear the gloves
guys pretend to be handcuffed and wear
the gloves the left is never going to
hold their own accountable because it's
awful i mean i'm doing it right now but
well
i
i was scared i was angry i could not
believe it i was like what is happening
how is this happening yeah this is this
is the way i couldn't believe it the
weird contradiction though they don't
hold each other accountable but they do
falsely accuse each other
like they they it's a circular firing
squad what obama called it yeah so it's
like
you'll watch someone on the left do
something egregious and they'll look at
you and be like so what wasn't there a
famous comedian that just got oh yeah
dave chappelle yes dave chappelle the uh
antifa
threatened the venue i guess and then he
he bailed out the left used to love dave
chappelle
but why who did he attack what what was
that it was because of his transphobic
remarks so what were his transphobic
remarks because i get accused of that
too
uh i mean he's made a lot of jokes about
like the whole trans issue i think he's
a kind of pigeonholed himself in that
way
uh i don't think they're super funny
personally but like
i mean
obviously the left has decided that the
trans issue is like taking priority
right now it's the gold medal because
it's like the ultimate lie that you have
to believe in order to be part of their
group
um so like some of the venue staff was
doing a strike and
uh
then the venue i think was
just sorry that they got caught they
kind of wanted to have him on under the
radar and then apologize afterwards
i saw their post on instagram about it
saying like we want to be a safe space
for everyone we're not we're not just a
black box with people in it we're like a
home for
expression except for
dave chappelle and also you know that
like the next venue that is willing to
overlook that is eager to have him
because he sells out everywhere wow what
what the left doesn't realize
you know i've been doing stand-up for
20 years i've seen chappelle perform in
front of 20 people in front of you know
sold out crowds um
what they don't understand is they're
actually pushing more people
to the right because there are so many
comedy fans
of who are fans of offensive comedy
i say offensive things i'm a fan of
offensive comedy because a lot of good
comedy it comes from trauma you know
when people when people would ask me in
interviews like were you the class clown
i'm like nope the class clown beat me up
uh like a lot of comics are sad right i
remember
getting into comedy because i had a
really rough childhood and you'd use
humor to kind of
uh escape and same with you know um even
politics if you can make someone who
disagrees with you laugh that breaks the
ice and now you can have a conversation
right
and
so what's happening is
comics also they don't take crap and
they double down because to them comedy
is the religion which means that
i am constantly trying to walk that line
and see how far i can take an audience
where they get scared scared scared
scared and then i'm gonna hit him with a
punch line and then they're gonna laugh
even harder because they thought they
were gonna disagree so chappelle had
like yeah i'm not a huge fan either mary
of like some of the early like trans
jokes i'm like oh that was kind of easy
whatever didn't think they were like
hateful by any means then he gets
attacked as like the world's worst you
know transphobe whatever which is also
not physically assaulted on stage yeah
by the way yeah yeah does the same thing
that this uh representative was yeah and
he continued to say he handled that guy
um and so what happened in i don't think
his last special either his last special
or second to last special is he tells
this really touching story about a trans
friend of his who was a comic who he
would bring out on the road with him and
or or have open a couple times and
it was really beautiful and you could
tell that was him as an artist trying to
grapple with what was happening and then
they just went after him harder and and
his friend by the way committed suicide
um and he tells that in the story so
it's this tragic story and
it's what good art should be it's what
good comedy should be it's honest it's
edgy it's dealing with um the adversity
that he's facing and then again they are
acting like this dude wants trans people
locked up they are acting like he has
political power and he isn't just an
artist so now he's just labeled as that
and it's driving all these comedy fans
away from the left because they go oh
you just don't care about freedom of
speech or comedy it's the it's the
recurring theme of the meme where the
guy's standing in the middle and then
someone on the left shoves him to the
right and then he gets picked up and
they're like are you all right and the
left goes why are you siding with them
right
we gotta go to super chats
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends we are going to have an
uncensored
after show we'll be live about i'll let
it go up on the website at timcast.com
about 11 p.m so sign up and when you
sign up you're using parallel economy it
is a payment processor co-founded by dan
bongino it is censorship resistant and
we took paypal off the site because
we we don't like what they stand for now
i will i will add briefly too there's an
issue with foreign foreign payments i
guess that's we're trying to figure out
so apologies uh of course there are bugs
because we just rolled it out
we're getting to it but tons of people
have already signed up when you're when
you sign up support using parallel
economy on the site you're supporting
our work directly but you're also
supporting the infrastructure of
parallel economy and hopefully they take
over and they take over the the market
from paypal that would be fantastic
all right let's see what you got
doomsday party says hi tim hi tim cast
as an agnostic atheist i often wonder is
it possible to solve hume's is ought
problem and establish objective morality
in a hypothetical world where no gods
exist
that was the most atheist question i've
ever had i don't know i just have to say
it takes a lot of faith to be an atheist
it does damn it it's true you have to
believe that hard
that there's no god and no creator i
mean that's actually a lot of faith
if you look at look at nature and look
at
just look at how things work yeah i've
never been i've never been a fan i was
when i was younger i was very much like
there's no god i'm atheist me too and
then i actually just kind of read a few
books and was like i actually have no
idea no idea yeah but isn't that kind of
beautiful
right it's like just treat everyone good
like that's it or maybe that search that
you end up believing it's it's okay like
the whole thing is a process and
but it takes a lot of faith to take a
hard stance and say there's no god all
right fine
well we can talk about it
i love talking spirituality religion dmt
all that good stuff me too all right
bendy says mtg i want to apologize on
behalf of all of ma fourth district i
know how mr hysom and his staff treat
you i contact the office constantly to
remind them of their unacceptable
behavior what is it what is that about i
don't know hi some historical that's the
that's the chief of staff for the
democrat representative that has been
targeting me for months and months and i
want to tell whoever that person is
thank you very very much because i have
so many death threats and for uh months
i had no idea who this person was that
kept targeting me attacking my faith
attacking my christianity attacking me
as a woman
and and my belief and my freedom of
speech to say there's only two genders
male and female so thank you so much
uh for for trying to hold your
representative accountable i really
appreciate it and um it's wrong it's
silly it's over a sign but the fact that
you know
they push and push and push what they
think and they believe and what they
want and expect all of us to just take
it but yet i am attacked constantly for
standing my ground and saying no this is
this is the hill i'm gonna die on
there's only two genders and i'm going
to protect children and and stop all
this gender brainwashing stuff you know
i've been attacked relentlessly so thank
you very much for for trying to tell
them to stop can i ask you a question
about that um
the thing that makes me
nervous
is so i've always i mean i started my
comedy career under bush talking about
like same-sex marriage um anytime i see
people getting discriminated against i
the instinct to me goes that sucks i
want to defend them right
and but then and i've lost some fans on
the left um and friends even for talking
about like i don't like like i have
trans friends um but i'm like i don't
like the drag shows i don't like the
surgery stuff the sports stuff confuses
me um
and i think that that should be a
reasonable uh position to not be exiled
from the left it is what it is the
question is and i saw this this week as
i posted about same-sex marriage
and somebody
said i used to be for same-sex marriage
but now i'm against that
because essentially i think gay people
are groomers right so how do we
differentiate between actual predators
groomers and then just like the lgbt
community at large like the suburban
husbands who are just kicking it well
first off i i think there's a major
there's a major difference it's not
i don't actually i don't want to know
what people do in the bedroom together
it's their own privacy to consenting
adults it's like you don't even see
those hunter biden tapes again god
forbid no
but but but sincerely though their
grooming is a real thing and and
children are so impressionable and we've
got to protect kids and kids go through
identity crisis oh my god i mean and how
many of us wanted to be something when
we were 10 years old or 15 years old and
we totally changed our mind when we
became adults we got to leave kids alone
let them grow up but you can't
this this telling kids they can change
their gender is so dangerous it's child
abuse because puberty blockers um these
these medications they sterilize them
medications they they hurt their health
and then
mastectomies teenage girls having
mastectomies
toys yeah boys actually having genital
mutilation surgeries
yes that that actually you know what
that does they have terrible issues
their entire life and it's horrific
these are things we have to we have to
protect children we have to protect
children at all costs and um
we can't go to the place where we're
teaching a lie
all right let's read some more we got
jason fisher says to mary eric july just
started his own comic book company
called the ripaverse it would be cool to
have him on pop culture crisis to talk
about it
yeah we were talking about that on the
show the other day i think it was last
week um
i know he's been on irl right he is yeah
yeah we would love to have him we can
have him on both shows that'd be cool
can you go on pop culture crisis then
later in the totally and chad hanks yeah
yeah he's been in the talks i uh
saying yes i've been texting with him
i'm working
i'm working on it yeah oh cool wow
that'd be awesome yeah the second he
started following me on instagram i
frantically texted mary and brett's
screenshots i'm gonna i'm gonna read
this comment because i want it to be
brought up raymond g magazine jr says
marjorie do you agree with mcconnell on
not wanting to impeach biden for all
obvious crimes against the us
we need action to forward the line
i i just i know your answer and i agree
with it and i want to hear it again so
absolutely
impeach biden immediately tim is
requesting the mercury hits yeah yeah
and i think mitch mcconnell needs to go
too it is oh i'm with you on that yeah
i've met tybee's reporting on ukraine
with what joe biden was doing the
obvious quid pro quo i'm sick of it we
we need some leaders to go in there and
just calmly and dispassionately say
here's the allegations here's the filing
i love how you i haven't read those yet
yeah yeah that's uh
victor shoken the prosecutor in ukraine
was actively investigating barisma where
hunter biden worked and joe biden went
in and said fire the prosecutor or i'm
withholding usaid to ukraine and they
said you don't have the legal authority
to do that he says try me call the
president like the most obvious illegal
activity it's joe biden is on video
saying he's saying this saying he did it
lock him up yeah for that reason alone
that was my first set of articles of
impeachment he's
it's abuse of power he's compromised
not too good all right all right here's
a good infernal machine says is it true
as reported by the hill that milo
yiannopoulos is now a congressional
intern for marjorie taylor green it is
true
he is an unpaid intern yes it is true
working his way to the top he does a lot
he does a lot he's great wow that's
actually i love that story wait hold on
is this not a bit it's real it's real
yeah it's legit oh no can i ask you i
thought that was a bit can i ask you
about i'm not a comedian
you are you're very funny marjorie can i
ask you about uh off pack three and your
experience there i was not like
so i went and gave a speech there it was
oh my goodness so many young people
um didn't know much about the group but
gave the same speech i give everywhere i
give i give that speech to like uh
democrat union workers give the same
speech in my district how'd they receive
it they loved it
nice so did the democrat union workers i
just saw so many people were tearing you
apart for that and it's not unfair they
did you know i resent the reaction
because i don't believe in canceling
people
and i think that's wrong and i don't
know why it's wrong to talk to everyone
why is that wrong but no i got attacked
uh even by the right oh i gotta have a
more attack by the right actually yeah i
got canceled by some people but and
that's unfortunate
and um i don't think i should just
because someone else doesn't like a
person i shouldn't take on other
people's enemies those aren't my enemies
i i'm literally just working for the
good of our country and i think that
involves talking to everyone and i think
those kids needed to hear what i had to
say all right we have a question that
you wouldn't be able to answer if you
could i think
sam you ray says will mtg take a v take
vp in a trump or to santa's ticket oh
i would heavily consider that oh wow all
right i don't know that it would happen
i would imagine the establishment on the
right would do everything they could to
stop it i wonder what a trump desantis
ticket would look like how the how the
establishment right would react to that
um
i don't know i don't see anything wrong
with it what's wrong with that no no
they really hate trump though that's
crazy oh they hate trump they hate him
all right let's see
john white says my name is john i'm a 33
year old white male been listening
regularly for two years and have lived
in the az mountains for the last 15
months with my wife two young boys and
chickens no regrets hashtag carrie lake
awesome ooh go carrie glad to hear it
yes she's great she is great yeah you
know you know what i find is that
i mean i think you were even mentioning
it the the people we end up having on
the show
like you carry or thomas massey or
whatever just act like real people
yeah we've i've talked to politicians in
the past and it's just like the canned
plastic response that you're like okay
i think your podcast is the test right
can you stand up i'm serious if somebody
can't come and be on your show then and
just hang out yeah he was the
congressman who the second he saw my
cauliflower is downstairs was like let's
wrestle oh yeah yeah
but
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we started
grappling downstairs and i was like man
i may not agree with all of you guys but
you are a lot more fun chomsky didn't
try to wrestle me when i interviewed him
come on man
that's awesome
all right
latina prepper says mtg for president
woo and then a bunch of american flags
and heart emojis ah
all right creamer of the dairy squad
says tim make an american dad ask
animated sitcom then i'll sub to your
site
it's very expensive i mean we're making
a sitcom
so i would still do it yeah yeah also
you get to hear the uncensored version
of this conversation afterwards so why
wouldn't you why wouldn't you support
someone who's bringing you real news
like this right that you're not going to
hear anywhere else yeah one of the
things with the vlog is that it was in
dire straits and people people
people who like the current iteration of
it need to understand that it was like
an untenable situation it was it was
money going into a project that was
slowly just about to evaporate
and so i was like let's breathe some
life into it and try and just
make it something better and new and now
it started turning around it's been been
improving some people might not like
it's a dramatic change and identity of
it but it's i think better than just
shutting down well also i mean the the
the compliments that we have gotten and
the callbacks to the inside jokes it has
been so cool and now we get to make it
like an actual show and i just watched
the first cut of like the first episode
and it's it's so it's the first longer
form one the first longer form one it's
so fun they were like 10 minutes and now
they're gonna be 20 minutes once a week
and uh the best part is by putting it on
the website we can actually make edgy
jokes that youtube would ban you for
that's not even offensive it's so dumb
and i made them uh they are on episode
one there there there are political
things you can't say on youtube and it's
the stupidest thing even it's ridiculous
you can't trust the machine to give you
uh the algorithms the the the voice
recognition thing to understand a joke
or context so and we're not on youtube
right now we are yeah oh we're still on
it yeah we're still on youtube for about
12 more minutes yeah
yeah
we actually end the show with me
teaching how to give an abortion on
youtube it's very it's uh okay all right
everybody
we're gonna try not to teach that got it
got it
i'm learning hey just let me baby step
my way to you guys all right
all right
angel torres says marjorie would you
agree that president trump should
mandate trade school programs in high
school with our taxes instead of paying
for college debt
oh wow i you know college debt that
that's that one's tough i don't think
that the government should be paying off
people's college debt but i am a huge
believer in trade school i think that's
where most young people should go
because you know something those are
awesome degrees and that they lead to
high paying jobs instead of a bunch of
student loan debt when you can't get a
job
the isaac glover show says it's okay
jamie we'll slowly but surely massage
you into becoming fully pro-life your
destiny is the dark side every day on
twitter you guys you guys all make me
laugh because i'll just get these like
either red pill emojis or
i'll tweet something that's like
centrist and literally all your fans
will just be like it's happening just
tweet me that the left calls this the
love bomb
they claim that the right will be really
nice to you to trick you into joining
their side well it works everybody
what do we do to them after they've been
tricked like what's happening yeah
i know i'm like what's the bad part guys
love bombing rules
but it's like it's nefarious they're
just trying to be nice to trick you and
it's like
maybe you should take a take a note from
that and be nice to people well and
here's the thing too it's
nice on top of the fact that we have
disagreed and have asked each other
questions and have
like
that's the difference right
you're still trying to get to the bottom
of things and this notion that if you
become
more centrist or if you're a liberal and
you take on a conservative view on like
guns or if you're a conservative and you
take on a liberal view and say like i
don't care if gay people marry or
whatever somehow you're like a grifter
or a sellout instead of like no man
people are complicated and there are
gray areas and it's allowed to have
you're allowed to have friends and
thoughts on both sides i think that is
healthy
it'd be boring if we all agreed the
worst rj says i'm pro-life and i support
the death penalty for murder i argue
executing a murderer upholds the
sanctity of life pro-life does not mean
anti-death yeah i was just talking about
there are so many cases that um
are
you know we either find out like oh no
maybe he wasn't guilty
right yeah and then it's like well what
do we do right that's why i oppose a
death penalty yeah like life in prison
is pretty rough but at least you can go
back on that yeah what are you doing
well no one's more innocent than an
unborn child correct yeah that's what
are you
are you pro-death penalty
yeah in some cases i am
my concern with it is
i i just use the
i think it's kind of unfair to do but i
think it makes the point i don't trust
kamala harris to decide who deserves to
die
because she
she's in california and this is what
this is you know basically what she's
doing and then i said do you think that
she's going to make sure that the people
who are on death row are all
truly guilty like if she came to me and
said tim that guy right there killed a
man and i want to put him to death i'd
be like i don't believe you like go away
i don't take your word for it um so the
challenge is i know people have said
like tim if someone like on video you're
watching him do something you know
there's a risk there's no rehabilitation
i'm like i get it i get it the challenge
is
in a very specific simple context i
understand that but creating a legal
framework that says trust the state to
kill people i'm like right
that's a very hard line it's a it's an
extremely difficult topic but i think
i'm a believer in prison reform i think
we have a lot of issues in the prison
system
uh when i went in the dc jail one of the
things that really bothered me other
than how the january 6 pre-trial
detainees were being treated
was i saw people
in extreme suffering in solitary
confinement in other parts of the prison
and they were in there because of
violence and attacking the guards and
all kinds of issues but that is
suffering as well and how are you how is
that going to rehabilitate them it's not
right and it's it's just oh i don't know
there's a lot of problems there and i
think we should do better stop love
bombing me with prison reform ian likes
to uh talk about shea's rebellion are
you familiar
yeah shortly after the revolution you
had a bunch of guys who were not paid
because the u.s was broke as a new
country so they revolted and then when
they were captured and arrested i can't
remember who because you know he talks
about it they were pardoned like all but
like three guys were completely pardoned
they were like we cannot do this a new
country cannot just you know hang or
punish these guys because they were you
know indebted you know we we owed the
money and we couldn't pay so he's like
let him go let him go simmer things down
calm things down i think
i think the republicans got to get into
november
and look i think anybody who is smashing
you know attacking cops and shoving and
getting violence should they should they
should build accountable yeah i do too
but we need
real leadership because the democrats
won't do it to go in and find all of
these people who are being abused in in
the dc jails and who are being wrongly
held over misdemeanor nonsense to just
be released pardon they should be
they've been it's time served it's
absolutely they should be released it's
too much
what they've gone through is too much
but the issue is that the democrats did
it it would actually be a de-escalate
de-escalating moment where they came out
and said were they to come out and be
like look we don't want to play this
game we're getting we're getting too
close they might actually win some
elections if they behave like that but
they don't aren't they the party of love
and tolerance they are funding trump
candidates while claiming trump
candidates are the threat to this
country which is a literal political
false flag operation what you didn't
know that no the democrats are literally
putting money into promoting trump
supporting candidates because they think
that's the play they think they have a
better chance of winning against them
yep the democrats governors association
i think putting a couple million bucks
into a couple republicans that were
pro-trump trump endorsed
yep
they think when the general election
comes they'll beat the trump supported
ken the trump endorsed candidate oh my
gosh it's a false flag i can't even
comprehend it and then they go on the
january 6 hearing and they're like this
is an existential threat to this country
quick give him more money yeah false
flag
it's it's scum it's scum it's it's man
that is an incredible lie
so they're lying on the january 6
committee and they've done it a lot
tonight and then they're going to paint
these candidates with these lies
and then they're going to put money
behind them
all right it's a terrible trick
khalis al bryant says signed up at
timcast.com today i dropped my hulu
subscription back in june because disney
owns a sizable percentage of it and has
gone off the deep end happy to invest in
a company striving to have a positive
impact i really appreciate it thanks bye
and i want to tell i want to tell all of
you guys
we i think a good portion of our members
who sign up are mission driven right
they see what we're trying to do and
they're like it's 10 bucks and it will
help make that mission happen i will add
to that
parallel economy is just getting started
we need them to succeed because paypal
owns like 80 of the of the online
financial market of transactions
whatever companies you can find that use
parallel economy start supporting that's
dan bongino's he co-founded it and we
also use the rumble player but i also
want to add
you don't have to sign up if our content
isn't good
my goal is to make sure that we have
good content so you don't even think
twice about it and you just go hulu are
tim cast and tim kes got better shows
yeah that's my goal also we care about
you like total shout out because i
talked a little bit about mental health
when i was on monday shout out to all
the especially men man like who don't
talk about this a lot um who hit me up
either on instagram or twitter to talk
about like the mental health comments
they were also saying that uh somebody
tweeted me that dan that's what reminded
me really helped him on the show as well
um
you want to support communities that
actually do care about you that actually
do have diversity and opinion that are
trying to make good content and not just
trying to to take your money so thank
you to everyone who signs up and man i
want to tell you about the stuff that's
coming uh but just get excited i wanna i
wanna read this comment from one of our
favorite um super chatters the real
hydro he uh super chats endlessly all
day every night he does uh often very
critical and sometimes to be completely
honest hydro i don't think they're
actual good faith questions but you do
make a good point here that i want to
address he says that tim flip-flops so
much he went from trump represents the
worst of america to i vote for trump
liberals don't commit wake up people um
my point about trump representing the
worst of america is the culture the tv
show the grab him by the you know what
the uh the horse face the you know fat
pig stuff
yeah i i say that all the time it's not
a flip up literally i think trump has no
there's a lack of decorum it's it was an
issue in my opinion but i don't think it
was substantial enough when it came to
the issues so the first time around it
was like i saw i saw the way he behaved
but also just didn't believe he would do
anything i had no faith in the political
system
then i watched this guy who gets smeared
and lied about in the media non-stop all
day every day actually did pretty good
then he comes out with his with a second
term agenda i actually really liked it
and i said you know what i don't care
all that much about decorum
i do think it represents the worst of
american culture but that's not that big
a deal to me when it comes to what the
country is i would take a donald trump
who goes on stage as the president calls
him on horseface who creates a great
economy and tries to bring about peace
in the korean peninsula over joe biden
who can try and be nice and then sells
us out so hillary clinton was the worst
of american government crony corporate
garbage i've long maintained i am not a
big fan of trump's demeanor
but that's like
on a level of importance not that much i
can understand why to some people it is
but
i think trump did well enough to where
i'm like yo give me the mean tweets i
don't care literally right bring a good
president about if hydro doesn't like
trump's comments he should he should
read some of the stuff the left says
about me or my face i think hydrax
really really likes trump's comments to
be honest i don't know for sure i think
he's just criticizing me because i've
been critical of trump you know and his
character versus why i vote for him like
i don't think that's contradiction at
all
i think in fact it's a good thing that
you have people who are like former
liberals willing to be like hey trump be
better do better because you are doing a
good job as president
uh at this point i put it this way we
were talking about your tweet
about rachel levine and we'll get to
that in the members only show okay oh
yeah
and i said you know what
i may not like it but it doesn't matter
i will never vote for a democrat because
they are pro child sex change operations
so does it really matter how it's framed
i'm not going to agree with someone
who's like don't say that we should be
giving no
sorry you know what i'm in
sometimes you have to call something
exactly what it is to make people
realize how bad it is because they're
calling it gender affirming care
and this is a man that's identifying as
a woman but yet he was a man most of his
life or is a man still
and is a father um but is but is
proactively
trying to force something on children
and being a part of it that will
sterilize them they won't be parents
genital mutilation and it's all going to
happen before they grow up i i just i
yeah democrats are on board with all
that stuff i just it's mind numbing to
me and they just lie about it so all
right let's grab uh let's grab a couple
more
uh let's see duloc says hey tim cass
your west virginian neighbor joined tim
cast this week dropped paramount plus
tales of the inverted world is fantastic
great great work guys yeah that dude
you know my my my dream vision and we're
gonna need like probably like two
million dollars to do something like
this
the goal for what i really want to do
with tales from the inverted world shane
is this he's a great writer it's
fantastic she's awesome i want to make
an actual fictional show
using those stories as as the basis for
an actual sci-fi investigatory show
hunter s thompson meets the x-files yes
so let me make the amusement maybe maybe
once we have you know like a 5 million
budget for a real show we can put
together our long drama sci-fi shows
where you have an investigative
journalist exploring ufos and
conspiracies guys just use congress yeah
yeah investigating congress i'll let you
guys come and visit me anytime y'all can
see what's going on oh my god we can do
like a congress ride-along
not like the stephen colbert film cruise
right yeah that'd be cool i mean it'd be
cool we're about to film in there and
everything too right yeah pretty sure
cool oh my god field trip
field trip all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com
we're going to have the after hours
uncensored show live at about 10 50 to
11 p.m and we'd love to see you there
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
you can follow me at cast marjorie would
you like to shout anything out i would
just like to make sure everyone orders
their handcuffs to be sent to aoc and
elsa what you're promoting yeah yeah
because these girls they really made me
angry this week by lying to everyone
cuff the squad.com
cuffthesquad.com make sure if they're
going to fake being arrested they've got
real handcuffs to deal with
um my twitter is already blowing up and
i want to read this comment from ratsu
don't listen to this these psycho
righties they love bomb you so you end
up happily married with children and
rich enough to be upset about taxes wait
wait what uh
guys i'm gonna lose a lot of followers
tonight so i would recommend that you
follow me to make up for that you can
follow me at twitter at jamiekilstein on
instagram where i talk more about like
mental health stuff like that at the
jamie killstein i'm doing stand up in
houston august 5th and 6th you can get
tickets at riot ht x dot com and go to
timcast.com and check out all the cool
stuff that we have coming up on the new
cast castle sitcom slash vlog
i've quite enjoyed sitting in ian's seat
tonight it's been real it's been groovy
uh if you want to find me elsewhere you
can follow me on instagram or wechat at
closer kitty and of course go subscribe
to pop culture crisis on youtube we go
live every monday through friday at 3
p.m eastern noon pacific time we talk
about all the entertainment news and we
have fun over there so come join us um i
also forgot really quick i forgot to
plug uh vote trump for president sorry
guys
i guess when he's coming yeah we're also
uh going to be having pop culture crisis
premiere on the website the same as tim
cast irl does so we're really gonna be
building up the site and uh cool cool
new technological developments coming
they're sure rules
thank you guys for tuning in this
evening for our i think is our third
show with marjorie taylor green we
always have a great time with her she's
always lovely despite what the media
tells you it turns out the media might
be lying to you i don't know just a
theory you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com at sourpatchlids as
well as sourpatchlist.me
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com in about an hour
uncensored thanks for hanging out
you